[Musique]
ce jeudi 20 juillet à la maison
régionale des sports le comité régional
olympique et sportif de la Réunion
donnait le coup d'envoi officiel des
Jeux des îles de l'Océan Indien pour la
délégation réunionnaise l'occasion de
réunir l'ensemble des partenaires le
département la région la préfecture et
l'accompagnie air australe à un mois du
lancement de la 11e édition à Madagascar
comme je l'ai dit 40 ans de partenariats
sur cette manifestation auquel on tient
particulièrement
au-delà moi de l'aspect purement sportif
c'est une vérité nos athlètes partent
pour gagner mais surtout pas à la
rencontre de nos cousins de l'océan
Indien et c'est je pense la grande
réussite des Jeux des îles c'est le
précieux qu'on doit garder absolument
avec 450 de sportifs et 268 personnes à
l'encadrement le club r se prépare à
représenter les couleurs de l'île dans
les 19 disciplines de la compétition qui
se tiendra du 25 août au 3 septembre
prochain c'est vrai qu'on a eu beaucoup
plus de moyens et beaucoup plus de temps
même s'il y a eu le covid que la
précédente édition et donc moi je suis
persuadé que nos jeunes sont bien mieux
préparés que qu'en 2019 les links sont
effectivement mieux accompagnés à la
fois par le la région et le département
et le cross a pu prévoir bien en amont
des possibilités de d'organisation des
déplacements et ça ne s'est pas passé au
dernier moment comme la dernière édition
une préparation sereine voilà qui met
nos sportifs pays dans de bonnes
conditions pour tenter de faire briller
la réunion au jeu des îles à Madagascar
[Musique]